we have built a virtual slow-motion
camera where we can see photons or light
particles moving through space now you
have seen dr. Jordans pictures of a
bullet through an apple but photons
travel about a million times faster than
bullets so our camera can see these
photons or bullets of light traveling
through space we use a very regular
pulsed light source and a camera that is
not one camera but an array of 500
sensors each triggered at a trillionth
of a second delay so even though each of
our centers is slow we can still capture
a fast movie I'm standing next to our
laboratory setup here this is our camera
objective is in the front here the body
of the camera is much larger than what
you would expect from a regular camera
like the one over here our light source
is a titanium sapphire laser that's over
here and emits a beam of very very short
pulses and that those pulses are then
directed to the scene
because he smears
now our camera only sees one dimension
so it makes a fast movie but it makes a
fast movie of one line of the scene only
you know in order to fix that we have
these two mirrors here we look at the
scene via these two mirrors and when we
rotate this upper mirror here we
actually see different lines of the
scene so what's happening is the camera
keeps taking images and we very slowly
rotate this mirror to scan our field of
view across the entire scene and because
all of our paths look the same the Canon
in the end go and combine all these
images that we took to get one complete
movie of the scene such a camera may be
useful in medical imaging in industrial
or scientific use and the future even
for consumer photography in medical
imaging now we can do ultrasound with
light because we can analyze how light
will scatter volumetrically inside the
body in industrial imaging one can use
the scattered light to analyze defects
in materials and in consumer photography
we are always fascinated with creating
lighting effects that appear to come
from very sophisticated light sources
but because we can watch photons
seemingly moving through the space we
can analyze the transport the movement
of these photons and create new
photographs as if we had created those
expensive light sources in a studio